I'm sorry is Marcus Collins and I am
beyond excited to be with you guys.
A little bit more about me. I've a
professor at the Ross School of business.
How about teaches marketing,
farming go blues and absolutely a warm
audience right now but that's actually
the side kick.
The full gig cause I work at an
advertising agency called donor based in
Southfield Eagle.
I work in advertising.
I'm not necessarily an appetizer by trade.
I was an engineer Undergrad,
ended up leaving engineering
because it wasn't that fun for me.
No offense to engineers in the room.
They went to the music business before
realizing as are getting a few sucks.
So I came back to school and figure it
all out and then went out to go work at
apple,
Beyonce in the advertising industry and
right now in the space I'm working in is
this notion of customer connections
that is understanding the Bobby media
landscape. That is the technology that
we use is shit's data about ourselves,
which you guys know very,
very well.
Obviously understanding
the behavioral sciences.
It is the causality based theory that
God's the behavior that we take one and
lastly having a very close
proximity to culture.
Now I thought about coming to visit you
guys to speak with you today. Is that,
what did you tell Google?
What do you talk about it the folks at
Google and figure I talked to you about a
very simple concrete
concept perspective.
Now I love perspective because we've
talked about a lot and we all have one but
really kind of boils down to this for
me that things aren't the way they are.
These are the way that we are.
That is the way we see the world ought to
be informed how we behave in the world,
the lens that we have. I would just
see the world influences the behaviors.
Got me to take all that and the beautiful
part about this is that we can look at
the exact same thing for two told him
perspectives is e two totally different
things.
Here's a way to tangibilize this tape for
us is my guards Georgia whitetail deer.
I guess she's the best and
even when she's like this,
Georgia is a fish,
like she loves to swim.
I take full credit for this.
My wife's over there
because,
but she was an infant.
We took to the whole idea of one of
these doctors check. There she goes.
She gets some air time
on the perfect. Yeah, no.
Here's how I saw it.
This is my perspective and I saw that.
I know George in the air just a little
bit. Nothing alarming. Just a little bit.
Droid maybe she started a little
bit higher and why? Why is
kill your child
so all the matter of perspective,
the way you said the world wants me
informs how you behave in the world.
Now I talked to you about perspective,
particularly about cultural now called
just one of those words that we use often
we talk about it and with
the media and celebrities,
like that's culture or if you're your
company you saying we have a foosball
table in the office. We have a great
culture here. We absorbed summer Fridays.
I have a great culture, but those
things are bipods and culture. Culture.
I make me buy it from the
perspective of anthropology.
Anthropologists describe
culture base look for things.
The other beliefs that we hold,
they all of the artifacts that we died,
the rituals, the social norms that we
hear too in the language that we use,
the lexicon,
the dialect and when these four themes
are adopted him on the plot as a people
is there to represent their culture,
right?
Getting tons of different ways and
that best in their nationality,
ethnicity definitely the religious they
subscribe to and oftentimes the passion
points that they hold dear.
Right and we use iconography to describe
and to project the cultures that we are
part of the cultures that we ascribe too
much like a peacock spreads is weeks to
meet. We do the exact same thing when it
comes to the brands that we hold dear.
Now Look, you guys are smart.
Obviously you said you like look is,
this is totally obvious but the obvious
use isn't top use until someone points
it out to, for instance, say someone's
going to get some headphones, headphones.
I go into target.
There's a long line of handball is
all the headphones look the same.
They all kind of have
the same sort of shape.
Which one are people most
likely to buy? Beads, right?
That just met,
but we know.
We know there's because beats is
the Silhouette America, right?
People need to listen to music using
beats assistance artifact that we wear
around our neck to say,
this is who I am.
These are the cultures that I subscribe
to. Now the beats bear the bowls. Yeah.
Yes.
It wasn't a die hard.
I want you to know is beats bear to Jbl.
They're my clients.
Like definitely say no.
Right? In fact, a couple of years ago,
someone dissected a pair of beats
by dre headphones and power.
Don't take $70 to make a beats by dre
headphones. They will see their delight.
It's no wonder then
why they dominate the market.
It's not because of the value propositions
of the products is because of the
brands prox that needs a culture because
culture sidesteps all the conventional
wisdoms that we know of or think about,
we think about marketing is more
powerful than my razor sharper.
My battery last longer, my car
goes faster, it has more body,
my dealer would get too late.
Right?
It's more powerful than all those themes
because culture is associated with your
identity,
the way we see ourselves and
how we want to be seen as big.
He once said,
if you don't know
what this is, Chris, a
little bit tiles, right? Uh,
what did they call it?
And we know that
Ms. Harding be introduced that language
to us in her record. Hold on, go.
Right, which wouldn't number one on
billboard I killed, murdered, I'll be war.
Right? That would be a burden on
billboard when Cardi B with number one,
the black yellow,
she also saw a 217% increase in search
traffic for crystal blue of the times,
which was equate to about four point
$5 million of media about the culture
drives covers. And if you don't know, no,
he has no, this is Jordan, right?
It's okay. You should stop yourself.
Store brand story.
But what else does it called jump man.
Jump Man. And he hit 2016 full
jumped over John [inaudible].
Yeah, man, it's way into the
culture back here. By the way,
let me translate this for you.
Adidas boot for beating number three,
shoe manufacturer,
sneaker manufacturer in the country
and over to brand Jordan in 2012 right?
Kevin, number two and a lot of us is
tribute to what they call the easy effect,
kind of knit the easy's
and just dominate things.
It was also attributed to for
rail in Stan Smith, right?
And just actually Q 12 Adidas,
Nike execute 12 cells.
This isn't the first time we've seen this.
We also saw it with run DMC.
The impact on culture drives commerce.
You guys know this guy, right? Of course
you don't just got the most evil rapper
best tossing myself, right? You can't
go anywhere without hearing a drink.
Predator drank is the guy and we know
that Drake is very closely connected to
his beloved city of Toronto and just
recently in fact somebody acquainted the
value of Drake on the
economic power of tomato.
That tricks talking 5% of the economy.
It's wrong because there's the six
barbershop cause the sixth restaurant does
the sixth Nelson Law and all of this
language that was introduced by trade that
is ridiculously powerful,
unreal, powerful.
This what culture does.
This is the impact of culture.
The beliefs that we hold,
the artifacts that we've done,
the behaviors we take on and
the language that we use.
This is culture with a capital c
is this is just good pop potion.
Dog Argue that American culture is hip
hop culture like the evils of hip hop is.
I came from nothing to something and I'm
stunned knowing you is exact what I'm,
every culture is pull us up by
bootstraps now starting on you,
right,
which is no wonder why hip hop music is
the number one most custom Java in the
country. When we talk about cultural meat
culture with a capital C for instance,
go back to 2000 feet right in
the middle of financial crisis,
2008 and you had an uprising of people
who felt like capitalism was a very,
very bad thing, so much so that
they wanted to be counterculture.
We're going to be completely antithetical
to the capitalistic culture that we
lived in and we call these
people affectionately hipsters.
My hip was all about pushing
against what we know of capitalism,
pushing against what we know of adorning
ourselves with material so we can
express ourselves freely. They dawn,
uh, artifacts that were irreverent.
There are ironic in some cases,
you guys bought cars,
they bought ridiculous bikes
and the whole nine, right?
We're fixed rate the whole night.
What was the drink of choice for hipsters,
adult beverage stream choice. Pbr. Pbr.
Right now why can we are cause is and
the brand is all about your military
museum. They're all about individual
expression that eat those up.
The brand was completely connected
to what the hipster community,
the hipster culture was all about.
They found a uniting force based on
the conviction that they both share and
everyone who consider themselves
a hipster, we're drinking PBR.
Now you can look at that and say,
wow, that's it. It's pretty good.
It's pretty interesting.
But the impact on [inaudible] business
was through the roof hockey stick growth
at the time of the uprising
of this culture that we
all call hipsters. So much.
So attorney PBR until $1 billion business,
which is ridiculous.
And you can say that by, but what
would the rest of the market doing?
Let's tell you what the
rest of our was doing.
Everyone else was either
declining or flat lining. Well,
PBI was murdered. You
don't know. I didn't know.
We also know this when we
think about proposing, but
we propose with the diamond,
right? And why do both of
the diamond, I'm sorry,
but it was the diamond question mark.
Diamond diamond lasts forever.
And who told us that?
The beers. Yes. Beer say
diamonds are forever.
So if you love her,
do you love your loved one?
You're going to get a diamond and you
know you've been up close with a ruby.
She's like,
you're going to get up
close with the diamond because diamond's
last forever because diamonds are
forever.
So much so that as much as long as you
have that person save up three months of
your salary to show the love, then
this rock that lasts forever. Well,
I'll tell you why the beers tells you
that to last forever because the resale
value for time is actually pretty awful.
And they have a monopoly on of
seemingly monopoly on diamonds.
So they constrict the supply,
it took their last rep or dope,
they'll resell it because
you'll see that this is bogus.
And as a result,
when this campaign hit the market in
the 1930s you started to propose the
diamond and we see the same thing happen
in Japan and they rolled out the same
campaign.
Brands have an impact on
culture and impacting commerce.
And if you don't know,
we also see this and think about smiles.
You ever wonder why?
Back in the day people were mean mugging
and their photos and their portraits.
And then today we can't stop
smiling were all smiles, right?
The Kanye has some issues with this.
No one can say, well that's because
back in the day people's photos,
it was pictures.
We're taking the portrait and took a
long time and you can't hold a smile.
That law,
like their face gets 15 muskeg tea and
people kind of straight look the whole
time.
But even with the advent of cameras,
people still to very grim
grimace looking photos.
This wasn't because of the technology,
this is because of the culture.
The belief at the time was that the idea
of smiling and photos are in portraits
was child life was halfwit. You're
less thing. That was the belief,
which is why the first federal,
all of the standing president,
they do like he belonged to a conference
on there. I'm completely not happening.
No Julie happening there and even at
the turn of the century where cameras
became much more ubiquitous and
more people have access to them,
we still didn't smell very much in photos.
So if you are a camera company that
makes your business from people buying
cameras and buying film and
take a lot for lots of pictures,
people think of taking
photos as a serious business.
They're not taking a lot of
photos in that situation for you.
So Eastman Kodak say, we
got to change this up, man.
We have to reposition how people think
about what photos are meant to be.
Say to just the idea of the Kodak moment,
taking the photos about capturing,
preserving these joyous moments.
It's about preserving these moments
that we have picked up love.
So much saw that we say, Jeez,
when we smile and take photos,
completely changed.
Not only the belief but the behavior.
And fortunately when this rolled
out the turn of the century,
it measured very close to their line up
very closely with a study that was done
in one year were polls,
well,
it's up your photos over a century's time
and measure the curvatures of faces in
the fellows to see how often or how much
people were smiling and we saw more and
more, we smile. This is what we do.
Which is why that guy now looks like a,
this kind of gun and the results of
it was massive for coatings business.
Almost $6 billion collected
was 2005 unfortunately,
they miss a cultural shift
shift kind of play themselves.
You know how that ended up right? That's
a good, right? So why does this matter?
Why does any of this matter?
I tell you why it matters.
It matters because France who could
culture are more successful than those who
follow. That is branching,
push culture forward.
Brands who contribute the
culture almost [inaudible] file,
they can ship it to the beliefs,
the artifacts, but dawn,
the lames were taking on behaviors.
We take on the brands who lead that,
push it forward and people use those
brands that communicates with develop
themselves. Whether it's
apple, Nike, whole foods,
Starbucks, people get tattoos of
a Harley Davidson on your body.
You'll see my but I was not
in his tattoo on her body.
We use these brands to communicate our
identity and we understand the impact of
culture on commerce.
We can then superimpose it with what we
know of human behavior and this is what
we're imposed that well,
we know of people's behavior based on
the shedding of data to take on and allow
us to better connect with consumers.
We know who the ability off.
Here's a few examples of this in action.
So Netflix is one of our clients at donor.
And Netflix came to us and say, Hey,
you want a lost into season five
of house of cards. It's, you know,
it's got a lot of momentum happening.
Things are going well. Listen,
this is in the middle of the most,
the most divisive drama field election
cycle we probably have ever seen,
at least in our lifetime.
So how might we be a
part of this cultural,
how might we be a part
of the conversation?
So we took on the assignment and we say,
well, what coal be could we lean into?
What can we take advantage of? And the
first thing we thought about was, well,
the actual logo,
the shell upside down,
what and what does it upside down?
One flag signaling distress.
Exactly right.
Culturally we know that upside down
flag means trouble's a brewing help.
So we thought what more opportune time
then to launch the teaser for the season
five, a house of cards, a new season.
Then here.
So during the inauguration
of president Trump, uh,
we launched this little ticket.
I don't have
liberty and justice.
So zero media behind it,
which I know it's not heard,
these guys behind it.
We saw 100,000 shares per hour for the
first 18 hours of launching this thing.
Not because it was so radical,
but because it had a place
in contribute to the culture,
which allowed people to communicate
how they feel, which is ridiculous.
Really powerful.
Now you can look at how the car to say,
let's party culture development.
That's a cheap as a cheat code.
This is something that's not as
culture development. Hopital I,
he's will populate. Yes. Thank you.
So potbelly potbelly for those who
don't know what didn't say yes,
papa as a sandwich shop,
right? They sell sandwiches.
Zell toasted sandwiches
handed, uh, headed, uh,
milkshakes and daily big cookies.
Tm. Right? So that's, that's,
that's pot belly. Now pop
Bella came, as I said,
we want to tell better
stories about the brand.
We want to move from being this kind of
like culty kind of iconic brand or coach
Kinda brings what iconic brand bring more
people in and so forth. We asked him,
I was like, well, what do you
believe? Like, why do you exist?
What's the North Star that guides
you? And they said, well, you know,
we believe in fresh ingredients.
We believe that tastier sandwiches.
Like I didn't know that's what you do.
Why do you do it? What's the belief?
Very sinus setting kind of
approach. You said, well you know,
they'll know after spending
some time with the CTL.
Was Biz town founder
promising? No, basically,
I mean it sounds to me people
happy and make people happy.
Making these sandwiches.
That made me happy. So it was
happiness about, so we said,
well there it is, then you're not in
the business of making sandwiches.
In the business of happiness was,
we need to shift your perspective,
the way you see the world from being
in the sandwich business to be in the
happiness business.
So we took their communications
and Turner for being good food.
Good vibes to be just mine,
right? You'll just be to Belize.
We'd be,
the smiles were all about happiness.
So the question now became
so poor and we go after,
what do we target are these
guys don't have a lot of money,
they just don't write whatever currency
I have in my pocket right now is
probably more than a marketing
budget now about 20 books right now.
A lot of money. So we thought, well let's
start with the people who love you most.
The people who are a part
of your email distribution,
they are the most ravenous fans. They
love the brand. Who are those people?
Unfortunately for us, they had a list
of, they call them the sandwich board,
New People when they
sin rebates to the test,
new products with them like
this is like their people.
So we said give us those email addresses
and we took those email addresses and
we converted to the associating
Twitter handles and the idea was like,
let's find out who these people are
beyond being hardcore sandwiched fans.
So with Crimson Hexagon, which is
a an AI consumer insight platform,
we built this prototype and networking
mapping tool that allow us to take those
email addresses or it's 200 handles,
don't them into the tool and see what
these people have in common. Right?
So this is a rendering of it. So we take
these in all of these Twitter handles,
don't them into the tool and we started
seeing the connectivity between them,
the clusters that you see
our conversations not about
sandwiches or how these
are happening in their life that are
happening in culture and things of that
nature to get a better understanding
of who those people are.
And in doing this exercise
we saw four things,
four names that were disproportionate to
these people versus the rest of Twitter.
And here's the rarely are the first one.
There were hardcore sports fans and
truly believe that was very discriminated
because I like a lot of people
like sports. So I was like, ah,
don't know we had any
right to be part of that.
Then we saw Christians and
he was like hardcore, like
Joel Olsen, happy Christmas.
What does break is a happy brand or
the client. I think we answered that.
So we kept them. We saw some tech
start up, some Martech in particular,
the way it feel like what we had
any right to be here. Part of that.
But then we saw,
and we'll talk about music now again,
music is not very discriminating.
Everyone likes me is I haven't
haven't been somewhat in life.
We said I hate music because we need
that person. There are monster stay away.
Everyone likes music. So it's not
very discriminating on the surface,
but we look closer to the things
that are being shared. We saw it,
they were sharing soundcloud files,
which is really small in
comparison to Spotify or youtube or
very,
very small.
So that was up to for discriminating
get particularly sound cloud.
These aren't usually signed.
Ours.
Underground artists is a
way to discover you artists.
So we felt that music is probably a good
avenue for us to get into the culture,
particularly because we have live
musicians who play during lunch.
So now we got away in.
So we came up with some ideas with the
client and we pitched the idea is that we
love that, that, that, that give you
some of that. And the idea was like,
let's go test and stuff. Now usually
you get a focus group of people,
let's look at the work and say I like
that and I'll buy that because I liked
that work.
What's typically,
they're all lying because self
reported data is terribly flawed,
at least biased.
So instead of asking people,
cause we didn't have money to get it
wrong, what does that to ask their bodies.
So you part of the Michigan states,
you advertise in a psychology lab and we
volume respondence to look at the work
that we were proposing in a
full Facebook like environment.
So he saw some regular content and
then the work that we're proposing.
So regular content in the work that we're
proposing and all of these respondents
were there tracking or taking
their physiological response,
swept lambs,
heart cardio activity or
respiratory activity. Um,
eye tracking, zygomatic muscle, which
can smile muscle. And we were at Trinity,
but we knew of the psychological drivers
to those physiological manifestations
and the work that performed the best.
That's the work we put in the market,
making great sandwiches that
make people really, really happy.
It's Papeles mission,
but how do you own that position in the
social sphere when your annual revenue
is less than your competitor's ad budget?
We mounted data tech and genuine
happiness to feed smiles across the web.
First, we set our sights and arguably
the most unhappy place ever. Twitter,
there were a partnership with Crimson
Hexagon in AI powered consumer insights
platform.
We identified a hundred sad tweets and
had pot belly musicians respond with a
hundred original happy songs in real time,
all during one lunch day.
Turn that frown upside down
when we learn Pollis fish died.
We entertained her with this.
Sorry to get about your fish at
mag moles fell out of a tree. Yeah,
it's sweet. I'm glad.
No matter the problem,
we had a happy response.
Just going to tell you
you all the very best.
He flooded Twitter with
smile songs and Twitter. Wow.
They smiled back with the
good vibes didn't end there.
We helped entire cities in need of
happiness by creating the smile scale.
A one of a kind algorithm that synthesizes
everything from weather and traffic
data to results from major sporting
events and social media happenings across
key cities than automatically
serves customized pieces of content.
If it's raining in Dallas, they get
this. If traffic is bad in Chicago,
they see this and if Detroit's
favorite baseball team loses,
we cheer them up with this. The results,
10 times more brand engagements,
20 times more Twitter followers.
Overall we spread happiness to
more than 16 million people.
That's a whole lot of smiles.
The more important part of this is
that with only $60,000 media spin,
we saw 2.8% increase a store
fabric for the stores that we did.
The smile scale occupations, which
is ridiculously powerful. Right?
It's crazy crazy. Taking what
we know of behavioral sciences,
applying them to what we normally welcome
to the landscape and finding a vehicle
and access licensed to be
a part of culture. Now,
Netflix kind of sexy pop valley,
not so much, but sort of fun.
Let's get like really
brass tacks like CPG.
But this is not sexy by any stretch.
Let's Talk Pharma.
The Pharma, so far, my,
their apartment in fracture, right?
They Bacon. Awesome. Delicious.
Right now you're looking at an import
manufacturer like farmland. You say, well,
there's nothing cool about Pharma.
So soft farmland is a praying together.
They have no interaction whatsoever.
The hypebeast like supreme and
a port factual like format.
A lot of people don't know about what
would they have in common? Probably like,
I don't know.
So the question becomes
then what do you do?
Or what could be done?
Typically nothing until a brand
like supreme. Jack's your logo.
So supreme,
notorious for taking other people's
Ip and conquest in it for their own.
Uh, they took the local compliance
and we saw this like what do they do?
What do you think? It's illegal.
You can't do this, let's a brain.
But what they can, because they're
gonna do whatever you want to do.
And in those cases you have three choices.
You could either litigate,
but as you'll see some assist you get us.
Ignore it most.
Most people do because suffering
doesn't care. Or third,
you could join it as we decide
to do the guys from Stock X.
Imitation is the highest form of flattery.
Then supreme is truly
a world class kiss ass.
The legendary street wear company has a
long history of borrowing designs from
other brands and last week they added
another instinct classic. So their legacy,
the week one horizon has
dropped it without much fanfare,
despite bearing a striking resemblance
to the farm land bull to logo and
Missouri based pork producer,
probably be least
hypebeast company on earth.
That wasn't until Friday when the ad
roll business giant took to Twitter and
called out the apparent forgery causing
horizon at prices to immediately pop.
The hats went from $70 before the tweet
to as much as $100 after a 40% increase
over night.
Proving once again that street where
loves a scandal and controversy is the
cousin of hype turning off,
it'll be gay.
So we saw them Chakra, a logo
responding in sweet. And uh,
somewhat surprisingly like
Twitter crazy like Yo,
lots of energy,
lots of excitement.
But we didn't stop there because we
knew that car you hit Supreme's I'll do
another drop the following week.
We just have to do our own drop.
That is farm land opened up an Instagram
handle and we traded a look book where
we don our
farmers.
Our farmers are out there doing
what they do decked out here.
Okay.
All right. As the trades were
saying, we out supreme supreme
just got picked up and culture
got picked up in the trades.
It's got pick up in the hype piece
still just amazing, amazing stuff.
This is good. See everybody the best, uh,
the best payback to base that
was done the last couple months.
But this is really where it's at. How did
we find what we know of human behavior?
We know the evolving media landscape
though we know of culture to connect with
people in a real meaningful way.
I think about my job ultimately is to
translate culture for brands and they
translate brands for the culture
in such a way that they connect,
enroll meaningful ways.
And luckily I have a chance to do that
with some of the biggest brands in the
world, which has been awesome. No, that's
me. But why does that matter for you?
I tell you what matters
for you because cultural,
I was getting much closer to humanity
to connect with people in a really
meaningful way and what the literature
is showing us more and more the research
is demonstrating that people care less
about the product benefits and care more
about emotional connection. Our ability
to connect with humanity matters.
Mormon, how Sarma right. Three
is how long our battery last,
how much body is in our sample.
People care about human connections
and also drives a cash register.
We just pretty good but it's also
better to you individually as well.
I tell you what,
you know,
especially for people who
are just starting their
career or new meal fights in
their career,
trying to figure it out were costly
to try to find a way to our game.
What's our strategic advantage at work
so I can rise up the ranks so I can be
more successful and I would argue that
understanding cultural is a really
powerful way to do that because like
I know, I know you're surprised,
but I used to get in back
in the day [inaudible]
I was a songwriter for a living. I
released music. That's why I did.
I used to form opened up for what 12
jagged edge Gisa call like those days are
behind me.
I have a three and a half
year old attorney for for
and 14 and it seems like I
am my wife and my daughter.
We live on a cul de sac
and sometimes we're matching outfits to
get forward them on to our sandwiches
are like really,
really hard to be a part of it culture.
But for a lot of you,
especially you,
y'all know about Kodak did a good bit
of a pullback kilo. A lot of people,
articles, culture. If that
becomes your superpower,
that becomes your differentiator.
You think about your career,
how do you succeed in
the world of marketing?
You love it to culture because brands
will be cultural. The and follow.
You have that power right now, especially
those who are close to it. You know,
if like this guy,
you have all the tools available to you,
most of the culture,
stay close,
stay close to the
culture and stay curious.
This would be the differentiator that
helps your brands succeed by pushing the
contrary to the culture,
pushing it forward. Hope this
is helpful. Thanks so much
[inaudible].
Thanks for coming. I always tried
to get into your class and Ross,
but I never had enough big toys.
I'm curious if you could get any examples
of brands and trying to be like the
culture center, but then it
ends up backfiring. Um, and
it's a sort of the worst.
I mean unfortunately there
were more examples of that
and they are good examples.
Probably the most ubiquitous might've
been gov is a Pepsi to a cultural moment
and make it about people
to made about that.
And it turned to a meme that
was piled on their base. Right.
And then really the issue there is
that they'll keep playing Pepsi.
They weren't dog who is smart people.
Nda is from grade schools, right?
Smart people. It wasn't, they were
dominant as completely oblivious.
They just more closer to the culture.
They didn't understand the shared beliefs,
the artifacts, the social norms, the
unwritten rules, the legs that they use.
And it's the lack of understanding of
the nuances that gets you off step.
You don't understand the nuances,
that's when you play yourself.
So the idea is to stay very, very, very,
very close to the culture and all
times requires from being a part of the
culture as opposed to being a tourist.
Right.
That the day we used to call
it ethnographic studies, right.
But getting away way in.
Yep.
Marcus,
I think I saw an example like a week ago
of something you're talking about with
blood disease.
You see the tweet that when he set out
to where they were kind of dogging the
Nebraska coaches name is frost.
Um, and they said you have frosty,
which gives meeting white 40 nothing at
halftime and they put out a tweet during
half time and I'm Mexican.
You know what's going viral?
I see it on the national news,
I see it on ESPN, you know, um,
it's a good brass offense. We're not happy
because they said, hey, you know, we,
you know,
when these two and then Wendy's on
their official like Twitter handle said,
we're pretty sure that, you know,
the grass is, have a sense of humor.
Some of them were still on
the, and they said, well,
we based our period geodesic partners.
Yes, it was crazy. Again, wow,
we've got to talking about their food,
but then all of a sudden
a lot of people are going,
I'm going to go eat at Wendy's.
I just love that they got the courage
to kind of get out there and caused some
trouble. Think I winkies without
being very, very close to a business.
I think Wendy's bigger or number three,
and this makes,
why not throw some shots and their
entire strategy at this point pretty much
about the trolling everybody else.
We've got 12 and you don't get hurt.
Come on. [inaudible] at all.
And considering this is a
part of their needles now,
people don't make less
urine from the basket. Uh,
people have had pretty big skin becomes
that sort of thing, but they are,
they're hugging all the right nuance
of the culture they're part of.
And we see things getting shader,
we're going viral because people who
believe the same thing that Wendy's does,
their take on things people share
also, right? It's all about community.
Community is another way of talking about
the cultures that were a part of it.
You see a lot of um,
how you around like Youtube,
collaboration's Instagram collaborations,
these kinds of integrations
that brands are trying to do.
I'd be curious to hear your thoughts
on on that and whether that's actually
getting close to them
culture or if it's sort of counter so,
and so I like as far as like taking
advantage of a platform to do things
right or, or more like the collaborations
with the creators on those platforms.
So, so I, I'd say this, my
thinking about the technology,
the technology and the
Zeros and ones if you will,
the Zeros and ones are the
facilitators of networks, right?
Things that normally be disparate are
now connected things to day to day.
That that goes from one node to the next.
Um,
so same sort of thing.
And what we find when we extrapolate that,
and I want to talk about
the network of things,
that network of people and things,
what some of the network of people
and people and things like Instagram,
Facebook,
social networking platforms are connecting
people who see the world similarly,
we're all my affiliate and we connected.
That is they share the same beliefs.
Social norms,
break written rules and rituals.
So think when brands partner with black
forms technologies who understand the
dynamics of the network, the
dynamics of the culture, they,
they borrowed approximately,
right? They borrow.
The people know the culture better than
Nate too, to get them closer to it.
That's massively powerful.
The idea though is that it's always
going to be an outsource skills as I have
the capability of the brand,
right?
Capabilities about repeatability and
reliability. Not to outsource that,
that I really don't have it,
which is good because they get a chance
a couple of at bats to do something
powerful.
But it's a challenge for them because
it's not really inside the eagles were the
brand is all about.
Sure.
So if you're not a part of the culture
that you're trying to get close to and
you can run ethnography,
ethnographic studies. Yeah,
either tools they're available to us.
I mean,
I'm actually thinking of an advertiser,
a group that I work with
as aftermarket auto,
so it's exact opposite gender,
different age range,
different lifestyle entirely,
but I want to get to know that a little
bit worried Smidley so it's good ideas
for tools we can tap into.
Well,
I know one is called Google
did, which is why it's so important to
understand the evolving media landscape,
social listening, search
behavior, viewership behavior.
We get a sense it's a proxy to what people
do, what they believe, where they go.
They talk about what they believe.
We know what they were.
We don't artifacts like dogs,
any pictures of them.
These things provide a proxy that we
normally would have to go move with the
coal miners,
Noah coal miners do.
Instead we can see them from a
distance and a short sort of bursts.
Well a large representation of the
population that we can pull a sample world
stage. I'll say this is
the real thing. Right?
And it's not really defined by demography
is that defined by psychographics
either is defined by the beliefs that
we hold, the behaviors we strive to,
the language that we use in tech,
like search, like social listening.
Those needs provide a bird's eye view
as be normally wouldn't have access to
without a ton of resources.
And I realized like my ex caliber of
sorts is Google trends it crimson hexagon,
I use it for everything to
bet on people. Right. I can't,
I have clients across a wide spectrum.
Google after different culture
have different networks.
So it requires me to be able
to cold switch between them
and I can't do all that.
Right.
I can't be that close to all of them.
So I can either use people work with it.
They work the agency who are close to
the culture while you use some proxy via
the tech ops
with the social listening tools. Sorry, I
assume those are like paid subscription.
So I'm more thinking, you know, we,
we know the wealth of Google tools
that we have at our disposal are there,
are there free social norms? Dooley's
Twitter advanced search. Okay, cool.
Super free. Like it's not as
robust as using premise it or uh,
or hootsuite or something like that.
But it's free.
It gives you a nice down and
dirty look at what's going on.
Super Representative of a sample
of people. Absolutely. Yeah.
My question is,
you know,
like I know we'll have seen like the
Nike just do it campaign for example.
And so I guess my question is like when
making a decision to launch a campaign
like that, when it might be considered
well and that might be considered,
some would consider it to be,
um, you know, culturally, um,
polarize this or how do
you, how do you go, what,
how does a company make what decision
making built into that? So I get that,
well, it's got to conviction. What do you
believe, right. Simon Sinek would say,
why have you exists? People don't buy what
you do. They buy why you do it. Right.
What do you believe?
And I think the biggest opportunity for
brands aren't attacking to networks who
share the same belief as the brand
because those are the brands we use to
communicate. This is who I am,
this is how I see the world. Right?
And conviction by its very essence
requires saying no to things.
It required two and think that may be
dismissive to people grown into the
world's way. You do. And the
fact that night she was like, no,
we're standing with copper nick,
because he aligns to our belief system.
And if you don't rock with that,
then you don't rock with us.
And also people were burning
their Nike's and say,
I'm never going to buy another pair
of Nike's. You're going to die.
Nike or your company sucks for the
people who believe when Nike believes in
Stanley copy as well, what they say,
getting two pair, right? I want more.
I'm a buy more because this theme is
representation of our belief. So you know,
it's difficult. It's,
it's, it is a simple idea,
but it's not easy.
And we often confuse simplicity and ease,
right? Like losing weight. This is
a simple idea. Don't eat so much,
move more personably.
Anthony's right in.
The same thing goes with convictions for
brands like what do you really believe?
If you believe that,
we will stand up for that when
everyone else is sitting down,
when everyone else is,
it gets you where you stand up for it.
That is what conviction is all about
and the branch who have very clear as
salient convictions. Now, little do
people know what they believe in.
Therefore they use those brands but
all their actions or communication,
people that they hire,
those people come towards the brand.
I mean that's the idea.
That branch should have conviction on
just where they communicate but also
within the organization so that people
who are part of the organization,
they believe and they to preach the
Gospel and they to our democracy
representations of the brand's conviction,
et Cetera,
did.
This is about the nuances of the culture.
Like it's a hard one to say.
Um,
we pay mind to the nuances.
We feel like it's a real thing
if people know the nuances.
When someone is saying
there's appropriate like no,
you don't understand because the
brain has always been a part of this.
Here are all the Demassio representations,
the evidence that shows this
brand's always been this way.
So then doing this is not a,
is that the new,
this is writing a lot of people always
been about, but you got to be about it.
Like what did he say? Don't talk about
it. Be about it. Right. The same thing.
Okay. Um, so I'm really big
on like influencer marketing.
So like I know in the past sophomore
year with, we don't say, um, job to her,
um, little media formation
and she mentioned red
lobster and like, after that,
like sales increased like people are
going to relapse to. And then like,
just like last week, Kylie
Jenner, she put on her snapchat,
she had milk for the first time
in her milk, just like posted
and like all these things.
So my question is,
is like,
should companies or brands like continue
to ride that wave and like use that
celebrity or influenced her
to, um, promote their brands,
like chat to tap into other influencer,
other culture?
I'll start this and I'll answer your
question with a step back and then we'll
step into it. Is there first, it's like
unpacking this idea of influencers, right?
So we think of like the Kylie Jenner's,
the Beyonce is the Kanye is the broadest
influencers and they have influence,
but the lecturer described their influence
as ideological influence. That is,
we look up that we aspire to that,
but we don't compare ourselves to it.
Like we don't hear Connie likes
talking about where it has been. We,
and then we get our Toyota
like, I suck at life, takes all,
he has the most money in the guard,
paint our paycheck or I hate myself.
You don't do that. We compare
ourselves to people who are like us,
people who were part of the same network
that we're part of our peers. Um,
so when I think about
influencers at that level,
like they're basically contextualized
medium, they're bright wattage media,
but those aren't, but they're, their
media isn't what makes behavior stick.
It's your people which
makes behavior stick.
One would say that culture moves forward.
The basis of, one simple question,
do people like me do something like
this? The answer is yes, I do it.
The answer is no, I don't. It would
make a decision hundreds of times a day.
People like me do something like this,
so say I see Jay z where a
super cool hat and I'm like,
that's dope ass shoes a match it
I'm buying that happened, right?
I go by the hat and I go to lunch with
my friends and I sit at lunch and they're
like, what are you wearing? Like
you're like, you're like an idiot.
Take that hat off. What am I going
to do? I'll take that hat off.
Put it in the closet has never
seen the light of day. Right?
Our people are what makes the things
stick because our people are the people
that we want to be connected to.
As Aristotle was saying,
we're social animals by nature.
So do everything we can to connect
people who are just like us.
They scratch the same beliefs,
say social norms, same old rules,
and they use the same language,
right?
So I think about how we leverage
influence in this way. Well,
we leverage the media that they
provide for sure. Right? Well,
we have to make sure that there
is some concurrence that is,
there's a lot of visibility that
people like me doing that thing, right?
Like Beyonce says he does any good
I take is to red lobster, right?
And it wasn't a bit like
meeting to the girls, all,
you better take me to red lobster,
right? People like me do this.
And then I'm like, yeah, I'm gonna
do this as well. And it'd be,
it creates the cultural weight that
allows us to propagate across the network.
So the answer, the short
answer is yes, absolutely.
As long as it aligns to what
the brand's is all about. Well,
what's the most important is how do we
get it to propagate across the social web
to these networks of people,
these communities.
So that the behavior stick is difference
between like going viral and be
culturally contains the names just spread
person to person, kind of Peter out.
But it spreads from person to person.
It takes hold culture,
unpacking our beliefs,
behaviors, artifacts, language,
which was doing my doctoral
research. Thank you. Yeah.
Good. Some very respected
brands. So I'm curious, um,
what is your main criteria before he
decided to say yes or no to a client or a
project?
Uh,
so I don't make the calls on the scope
of work that the agency says is deemable,
but for me to work on the products there,
there's things that come into the
building that my teammates have.
Sky You don't touch. Um, and unfortunately
I'm, I'm going to place my career.
I can say no, not another festival
statements. Um, I tried to take it,
we'll see a wave. I don't
do the tobacco at all. Um,
and I try to stay away from alcohol
particularly because I'm consuming. Right.
And you know, I've worked with me,
I work was one of our clients. Um,
just the building. While
there may be some, uh,
somebody have issue with
Mcdonald's. I don't. Right. Um,
but if it has request for years,
for four years,
and I've never tasted the product at all,
right?
At that time I couldn't say dope bro.
Once my broker and say no today,
I'd say no thank you.
Just because this describes it
does it in a line to my beliefs.
There's a line to what
I like to do and me,
it'd be hard for me to sleep at night
telling people to consume more, some more,
some more tobacco completely against,
and therefore,
I won't even tell us this
stuff. But again, it's just the,
I had a question about what you've done,
who you've been apart of
brands or they're going to be,
the competitor has totally crushed it.
Like you're working Miller and QVR
sales are completely skyrocketing.
The move usually till it,
right on their success or take
the complete opposite stance.
I think it depends on where the brand is.
So if you're the market leader and
these guys are skyrocketing up,
you don't want to put the spotlight
on those guys. In most cases.
It's kind of like that's
the, uh, that will be,
that's the conventional wisdom.
I think about it.
Like are we Drake and push it to you?
We're beefing out this summer, right?
Drink is like here, Pusha t is not as
high as far as the claim. Right? Um,
who's t throws jabs at Drake,
Drake response can push it
to use rubber sales go up.
So all times will be the market leader.
Your job is just to say that the,
if your job is to grow the
market rolling category,
someone throw shots at you
or someone's rising up,
just make sure that you keep the category
growing until they become too close to
call.
In those cases you find ways to the
door of that sometimes acquisition.
Um, and then sometimes it's
finding ways to to blot.
Have you been a part of the branch
strategy that has successfully combat at a
major spike in a competitor?
Um, I would say so. State
farm, right? So state farm,
they are the market leader by far.
But you see a lot of market share being
acquired by particularly the Geicos in
the world insurance progressive.
All state. So state farm,
like how do you keep the category growing,
which the category is sort of,
um, if it's sort of self
moving because it's obligatory.
If you want to drive this country,
you need all of these rooms, right?
But how many people to get
on as soon to get it with us,
get a financial services and kid with
us while these other guys are coming to
the market.
So we found ways to use
culture to continue to boost
the brand and broaden the
aperture of the category.
Particularly during the clip Paul
Campaign for state bar. Right?
So instead of talking about
how we're barely in state hub,
we're better than Geico.
We just talked about how great the
state farm is that helping you with the
magical age and like the neighbor state
farm, is there a shows up or personify?
What happens when you have
an agent? What's the only
clip, Paul? Right. Chris Ball.
All Star,
state farm.
All of our all star point guard
who throws assist on the court,
Flip Paul All star state farm agent.
There was a system, real life,
all these things to manifest. What the
brand is all about so that we can grow,
grow as presence. Thank you. Got It.
So I'm kind of interested in
the brainstorming and then
zeroing in on what we're
going to do process.
Uh,
the example of Potbelly's she just talked
about and um, you're gathering data,
you're trying to understand what
the brand really wants to go to.
We're not just like sandwiches
but happiness. What does
brainstorming look like?
And then how do you say, okay,
this is what we're going to go for.
It cause going to watch a commercial.
I'm like,
I can't imagine someone in
the room being like, Hey,
this is what we're going to go.
I'm just wondering what it looks like to
brainstorm and then make that decision
on kids is what we're
going to move forward.
Radical simplicity. Just get
radical, radical, radical simplicity.
So brokers ask is brings is
what do we believe as a brain?
How do we see the world in the world
of I'm only behave in the world.
So what do we believe?
And once we realize what the why is,
what the conviction of the brand is,
now we know who we're targeting.
People who see the world way we do,
right?
So now we know who we are and how they're
going after work or who we went after.
The next question is what
do we want them to do?
Cause Marketing's one of those words
that we use, uh, full of jargon.
Distractions, buzzwords,
right? Like, well,
it's marketing asked 10 people
get 20 different answers.
So I think about marketing as radically
splits in simplistic as possible. Uh,
old Oxford dictionary defines marketing
is going to market like parking is going
market the market.
Being people with the core of
marketing get people to adopt behavior.
So we know what we're all about as a
brand. We know who we're going after.
Now the question is what do we want
people to do? And all the messages,
communications, campaigns,
uh, products, activations,
they're all designed to get people
to move as simple as possible.
All the other things that we built on
and the implications and what not we can
get into. But it all starts with
who are we? Who are we going after?
What behavior within the table?
My pleasure. Thanks so much.
[inaudible].